المترجم: Esraa Abo El-So'od
المدقّق: Modather Zaki
الآن سأحدثكم عن ريادة الأعمال
بالتحديد كيف تفشل في ريادة الأعمال؟
في عام 2012
أسست شركة مع شخص معروف جدا في صناعة الـIT
وانضمت إلينا شركة تمويل
دعمتنا بالكثير من المال في ذلك الوقت
وكان لدينا فكرة رائعة تهدف لتغيير صناعة
ال health care
أي الصناعة الصحية في البلاد
وأول ما ابتدأنا به كان تحديد المشاكل
الموجودة في تلك الصناعة
وكيف للـIT أن يساعد في تغييرها
فوجدنا أن الأطباء في بلدنا
لايستخدمون الحاسوب نهائيا
حيث توجد الأجهزة في الصيدليات والمستشفيات
نوعا ما متطورة في هذه المنطقة
والمعامل ومراكز الأشعة متطورين جدا
في هذا الجانب
لذا وجدنا أن المشكلة تنحصر فقط في الأطباء
فقررنا توصيل الأطباء ببقية الصناعة
وبالتالي يمكن تكوين صناعة كاملة
أو ما تسمى بالـecosystem
أن يكون
كل الصناعات ومقدمو الخدمات متصلين ببعض
ونخرج من هذا العمل ب medical records
أو ما تسمى بالملفات الطبية للمرضى
وكذلك يمكننا تطوير الصناعة الصحية
بشكل واضح جدا
قمنا بعمل تطبيق للأطباء في العيادات
التي كان اسمها EMR
أي Electronic Medical Record
عليها فزنا بجائزة كواحدة من أحسن التطبيقات
في Europe, the Middle East and Africa
من Microsoft
ثم ذهبنا إلى الأطباء وبدأنا في بيعها لهم
ماهي توقعاتكم؟ من يتوقع أن الأطباء ستشتري؟
لم يتوقع أحد أن تشتري الأطباء؟!
ليتني قابلتكم حينها
(ضحك الجمهور)
عندما ذهبنا للأطباء قالوا: "هذا ما نريده"
وبالمناسبة قبل الشروع في هذه الخطوة
قمنا بعمل research
دفع كل منا مبلغا من ماله الخاص
وأحضرنا متخصصين وقمنا بmarket reaearch
على 800 طبيب
وأنتج لنا ال market reaearch الEMR
لنحقق أعلى نجاح
ونزلنا لبيع EMR
ومن بين كل 100 طبيب، 72 طبيب يشتري
بعد 3 أو 4 أسابيع
ظننا أننا نكون فيسبوك جديد في مصر
حققنا نجاح عالمي بهذه النسبة
بعد حوالي شهر ونص أو شهرين
لم يستخدم أي من الأطباء التطبيق
لم يستخدمه أحد منهم
فذهبنا لسؤالهم وأتذكر جيدا رد أحدهم
عندما سألته لم لا يستخدم التطبيق
أجابني: أنت جيد ولكن أنا لا
(ضحك)
قلت له حسنا، أشكرك ولكن نريد حلا
لهذه المشكلة نريدك أن تستخدمه
حينها بدأنا البحث عن
كيفية نجاح الشركات العالمية
هل يوجد منكم من لا يعرف تويتر؟!
جميعنا نعرف تويتر
هل تعلمون ماذا كانت تويتر
قبل أن تصبح ما هي عليه الآن؟
هل لدى أحدكم تخيل؟
(إجابة أحد الجمهور)
ماذا؟!
تويتر كانت سابقا تسمى Audio
وكانت تسمح للمستخدم الدخول إلى Podcast
بعد عمل subscribe تتيح له الإستماع إلى
محادثات بين الأشخاص
ثم أطلقت شركة Apple الـI-tunes
فتخوفت تويتر من الخسارة
وخاصة أن هذا المشروع لم يسر جيدا فبدأوا
في التفكير في أفكار أخرى
ففكروا في عمل micro blogging وهي فكرة
محددة ب140 حرف فقط
ومنها انطلقت تويتر العملاقة المعروفة الآن
والتي لم تبدأ كتويتر
هل يعرف أحدكم Pinterest؟ Pinterest؟!
بدأت Pinterest كشركة تسوق حيث تتصفح
المحال المختلفة وتختار ما تشاء وتشتري منها
وهو ما انتهى به إلى فشل ذريع
وقرروا حينها إطلاق Pinterest
بحثنا خلال هذه الفترة في ماذا نفعل بعد ذلك
هناك جملة..
عندما ذهبت إلى سان فرانسسكو
مع شريكي أحمد بدر
كان لدينا مقابلة مع أحد موظفي Uber الذي
قال لنا: fail fast
استمر في عمل الكثير من التجارب وعندما تفشل
هذه التجارب، افرح
لأن كل واحدة منهم هي قصة فشل عرفتها
وأزلتها من طريقك
وفعلنا هذا بالضبط عندما عدنا
كما أخبرنا جملة رائعة جدا: أن الـstartups
هي الشركات التي تجيد فن التجربة
أو ما يسموها فن التجربة المنظمة
Organizations focusing on
structured experimentation
وهي كيفية خوض تجربة منظمة
وهو ما حثنا على عمله عندما عدنا
وبدأنا عمل تجارب شديدة التنظيم، جزء بجزء
والعمل مع الأطباء من سحب هذا وإضافة ذاك
نضيف المعامل أم نحذفها
إدخال المرضى وإخراجهم
أو جعل المريض لديه application أو لا
أو جعل المعمل لديه application، أو نلغيه
وظللنا نقوم بتجارب سريعة حتى وصلنا إلى 23
تجربة في أقل من شهرين
اختارنا منهم 3 فقط،
ومنهم أنشأنا شركتنا الآن
تتمحور الفكرة باختصار شديد جدا في كيفية
عمل التجربة
التجربة لها نظام، فعند قيامك بالتجربة
يجب أن تحدد هدفك وإلى أين تريد أن تصل
هل هدفي جعل الأطباء
يستخدموا التطبيق؟
أم هدفي هو إشراك المعامل معنا؟
ما هو هدفك؟
هذه واحدة من العناصر، وما هي التجربة
التي ستقوم بها؟
وهذه كانت أول خطوة وهي تحديد أول هدف لدينا
وهو جعل الطبيب يستخدم التطبيق
إذا نتج لنا أي ناتج آخرفلم نكن نسعى
وراء المال في ذلك الوقت ولا مبيعات
بل كان الهدف الواضح لنا هو جعل الطبيب
يستخدم التطبيق
فإن أخطأنا وزللنا وتركنا هدفنا وسعينا
وراء المال، لكنا سلكنا طريقًا آخر تمامًا
مثل البعض من قالوا لنا بما أنكم تقوموا
الحجوزات، لما لا تقوموا بها في...
هل تعرفون "اجنسات السيارات"؟ حيث تصليح
السيارات وما إلى ذلك
فلما لا تستخدمون هذه الطريقة؟
وهنا إن لم نكن منتبهين لما نفعله لأصيبنا
بفشل ذريع
لذا من المهم جدا أن تعرف وجهتك عند قيامك
بالتجربة
الشيء الثاني هو تحديد مدة للتجربة
ولا تخرج عن هذه المدة
وأن تكون مدة التجربة قصيرة، وثالث شئ هام
هو أن تكون التجربة تجربة رخيصة
قم بالتجربة بسعر رخيص
توجد شركة مشهورة جدا في أمريكا تسمى
(Rent the runway)
أشجعكم للقراءة عنها من المهتمين
بريادة الأعمال
هي إحدى الشركات التي بدأت متأخرة جدا إلا
أنها تمكنت من إنشاء شركة عملاقة بهذا الحجم
كانت تقوم الشركة بتأجير الفساتين
باهظة الثمن للسيدات في سهراتهم في أمريكا
وقبل عمل application أوwear-house ومخازن
وما إلى ذلك، اشتروا بالضبط 50 فستان فقط
وبدل من استخدام application
استخدموا الهاتف
فيتصل العملاء بالهاتف لطلب تأجير فستان
فقط ليروا كيف سيسير الأمر
واجهوا مشكلات كثيرة وظلوا يحاولوا حلها
وهذا بالضبط الفكرة من وراء التجربة
عند قيامك بالتجربة تكون رخيصة ومحددة الوقت
ومحددة الهدف حتى تستطيع التطور فيما بعد
شكراً